i'm paris this talk is about very visual
machine learning okay there's not a lot
of python in here but there is some
python
so i hope you'll forgive me it's not all
python
now
i'm a professional game developer i'm
not a python person despite having a phd
in computer science python still
terrifies me and i have no idea how any
of it works i am just feeling my way
around python so i'm primarily working
with mostly other languages i use python
when i need to get something done
because because it is usually the best
tool for the job
for like data munching data science
machine learning stuff like that as
we've heard today python is a really
great multi-tool i love my my dogs these
are my dogs you should also love my dogs
i'm from hobart which is where chris is
from
please don't hold me responsible for
chris
[Applause]
we're not all like that
some of us are though
uh
i read a lot of books i built a lot of
video games
uh this topic is kind of python adjacent
as i said we're talking about unity
which is a video game engine which i'll
come to in a minute that's c sharp which
is actually a pretty good language and
then we use python for the machine
learning heavy lifting which is the
machine learning bot side of things via
tensorflow you may have heard of it it's
pretty great
i'm going to talk about three things
today i'm going to talk about unity
which is a game engine i'm going to talk
about tensorflow which is a machine
learning framework that comes out of
google i'm going to talk about something
to glue them together which is the unity
machine learning agents toolkit which i
may occasionally refer to as unity ml
agents unity ml or various other things
all these words are wrong it is called
the unity machine learning agent toolkit
they get very angry when you call it
something different
unity again game engine
this is a quick introduction to the
power of using a game engine or a
simulation engine for machine learning i
think this is really cool and more
people should be doing it so hopefully
you'll get enthused by this we haven't
got time to go too in depth
first thing i'm going to do is look at
unity uh
i'm going to quickly tap out of my
slides because i think it's best to do
this live because i lost half my slides
anyway so please excuse me while i tap
on my slides in a second but basically
unity is a game engine unity is
60 to 80 of the video games industry
depending on how you count which is
terrifying no one company should have
that much power but there you have it we
have that problem that's our own problem
to deal with but unity is mostly free
and it's really useful to play with uh
it turns out a game engine can simulate
enough of the real world to be useful
for people who need to simulate the real
world and pretend something's in the
real world which is actually quite a fun
thing to do
so
alongside game engines being a big thing
and unity being a ridiculously
terrifying percentage of the games
industry
machine learning has really taken off
lately in three very specific different
domains
those three domains are cognitive
physical and visual so we've got alphago
doing cognitive things solving cognitive
problems we've got
deep mind and like the open ai gyms and
stuff like that making things walk with
like weird throwing motions and stuff so
physical problems
and we've got visual problems like viz
doom where they taught a bot to play
doom just by giving it the visual input
of doom okay doom is the old video game
so cognitive physical visual as it turns
out a video game engine can simulate
cognitive physical and visual things
very easily and very quickly and it's a
really good place to do that stuff so
that's where unity comes in
this is the ml agent toolkit it's on
github we'll come back to that that
slides just there in case i didn't have
an internet connection
i'm going to tab out now and show you
this live just because it's easier you
do write a paper on it if you want to
read more about this from an academic
sense this paper is really good unity a
general platform for intelligent agents
it's on archive because every machine
learning paper is on archive it's very
it's very readable check it out
uh
so now it's almost lifetime time so i'm
going to push escape
and go into unity and i'm going to pick
the right unity because i have three of
them open to show you three different
things
that's that
uh
this one okay so ignore those zeros this
is unity uh in unity you may think it
looks like most other 3d software uh
this has nothing to do with machine
learning this is just a scene to
acclimatize you with how unity works so
in the scene i've put a ball into the
scene it's called sphere i'm going to
rename it to ball
you'll see it over here
i've got a cube in the scene which i've
flattened
so you can squish things i've flattened
it i'm going to call it floor
and on the ball i've said
this ball is made up of components it
has a position component which is called
a transform which is this thing over
here
it has a mesh which is a sphere it has a
mesh renderer which is the thing that
makes the sphere appear in the real
world in the game and has a sphere
collider and a rigid body these things
make it affected by the physics engine
which unity ships with i've also applied
a thing called bouncy material to it
which i'll show in a second but most
importantly i've ticked this box here
use gravity
and uh that means it'll be affected by
gravity as you'd expect now if i delete
this one because it's a bit of a spoiler
and run this simulation you'll see the
ball falls to the ground
and not much else happens okay if i want
it to bounce i need to give it some
bounciness so i've made this bouncy
material which is
a thing that says this is bouncy
not much not much to it and it's got
bounce combined and maximum which means
every time it bounces it'll get more
bouncy very exciting okay so i'm going
to drag that onto my ball and i'll show
you what happens then you can probably
guess
right very exciting okay that's my talk
no um this is not machine learning
this is ninja with machine learning this
is just a cool simulation of a ball that
bounces that ball will eventually bounce
off screen because we told it to
multiply its bounce every time it's very
exciting
hopefully this really quick example
shows you how easy it is to assemble
something that would take a little bit
more than the 30 seconds i took to build
this to code so you can build it very
visually very quickly so unity lets you
build 3d complicated scenes very very
quickly
and that is why it is interesting for
machine learning
so i'm going to switch to a completely
different scene now
we've made a little uh race track
which some of you may have seen before
if you saw me speak at pycon
with my little racetrack uh it's
pretty much what you'd expect it's a
really boring little race course
for the machine learning experts in this
room yes if we train a car to drive
around this track it will not drive
around other tracks very well it will
local maximum problems all that that's
not the point i want to show you how
easy this is in this track we have a car
this car is actually some sort of dozer
it's not actually
so it's a self-driving dozer more than
it's a self-driving car we're going to
make this self-drive around the track
and i'm going to show you how easy it is
to do that so the first thing i'm going
to show you is i have made this car this
is basically a game okay so if i hit
play now assuming i set everything up
correctly earlier
you'll see that this lets me drive
around the track
okay this is me steering i'm very bad at
steering i cannot drive in the real
world i can't drive on computers
okay so
there we go when you crash it just reset
you to the nearest point okay so
hopefully you all have seen a racing
game before or played a racing game as
exciting as this one uh you can see that
you know we can drive around this track
it's very good
that's not very interesting from a
machine learning point of view so we're
going to use machine learning to make
the car drive itself
the way we're going to do that is we're
going to make sure the car's camera is
fed into some sort of machine learning
system so if you look at this car if i
expand it over here you'll see that it
has a camera mounted
to the front right here
and it points forward so you can kind of
see the the view frosting of the camera
there's this like cone thing coming
forward and you can see a little preview
down here what the camera can see
so this camera is mounted to the front
of the car and if the car drives around
the track
which i'll show you in a second
you'll see
the camera the front of the car is
connected to it okay
so it's moving with the car
we're going to feed that camera into a
machine learning system and teach the
car to drive around the track by itself
the way we're going to do that is we're
going to use these white points if you
look on the track there's these orange
things here
which are spaced around the track
relatively evenly
let's manipulate my scene to show you
those so you can see one there
and then if i go
forward
okay so they're going around the track
when the car
leaves the the track and goes through
one of these colliders on the outside we
reset to the nearest shiny yellow thing
okay make sense to everyone pretty
straightforward
uh that's code i'm not going to show you
just trust me that works that's what was
happening when i was crashing earlier
now
i'm going to turn on some machine
learning and show you how this works but
first i'm going to show you the car's
code and if you don't like
c sharp it's time to avert your eyes i i
really like c sharp it's actually grown
on me a lot use the over the years it's
one of my favorite languages it's not
suitable for the same things python
suited before but it's a very good
language and so on right so i'm going to
open the cars code and this is the code
attached to the car itself so there's a
lot of junk here because unity is a game
engine and comes with a lot of
baggage because it's a game engine
basically we have we have a system that
simulates a car so if i look back in
unity for a second you'll see on our car
there's a whole bunch of parameters over
here that you know relate to cars
because if you want to build a car game
you need all these parameters we're not
using most of them in fact the car
automatically steers forward drives
forward it accelerates and we have the
only control we have is left and right
because we don't want to make a machine
learning bot that takes too long to
train
so if i go back to the code you'll see
we have all that all the junk to set
that up
the most important thing here is this
agent action thing which is a thing we
implement to adhere to the requirements
of this ml agent toolkit and this agent
action says
when this action comes in we either go
left or right it's either gonna be minus
one or one and we tell the car to move
with that action that's all that's doing
okay and then we check if we're collided
so if we've hit something if we've gone
outside the edge of the track we
penalize the car with a minus one
floating point
and we reset the car to its nearest
point and if we did not hit something we
give the car a very tiny reward
very small reward
very large penalty okay it's really
important that you tune these numbers
these numbers are more art than they are
science if anyone's under machine
learning you'll know that this kind of
takes a while to get right
this is something that we came up with
that kind of works okay okay
there's a collect observations thing
here which allows us to pass information
about the scene into the machine
learning system
we can give any sort of vector input we
want in here so if we wanted to measure
the distance from the walls we could
send invisible lasers called raycasts in
the video game world out into the walls
and measure how far away those are we're
not going to do that here we're actually
going to use visual observations so
we're just using that camera on the
front and that's a thing we can set up
visually inside unity
so
here we have an agent action the car can
steer left or right minus 101 and if it
hits something it gets penalized if it's
still driving it gets a small reward
okay that's literally it
back in unity
you'll see we have our camera attached
to the car
and we have this thing called a car
academy which is the thing that just
mediates between
the ability to learn and the ability to
control unity and here we have a
learning brain
i'm going to click control on this
learning brain this means
we're using an inter-process bridge to
talk to python that's all that control
tick box does
and if i show you the contents of that
brain you'll see that it has a
visual observation of 32 by 24 in
grayscale and that's that camera
attached to the car okay
that's that's literally it it has a
space type uh space size of one
one one one action which basically means
that vector has one thing inside it
which is a minus one or a one that's
literally it
okay that's the only setup we need to do
in unity so
i'm actually no i lie there's one more
thing i need to do there's this if i
connect the
learning brain to the car i had a player
brain there before which allows me to
drive the car with keys so this is what
a player brain looks like a player brain
just exists so you can use the machine
learning subsystem to test your world
and drive it around with the keyboard so
i had exactly the same setup here but it
was mapped to
keys apologies for sniffing it's been a
long week
so now we've set the car to use the
learning brain
we're going to go into a python script
very exciting first thing i'm going to
show you though is some hyper parameters
all machine learning these type of
parameters
very straightforward lots of magic
numbers
don't worry about it
okay has anyone done machine learning
and familiar what i'm talking about okay
yep high parameters lots of magic
numbers these have been tuned over the
last few weeks of us iterating on this
project to get it right
more interestingly we're using a trainer
called ppo which is called proximal
policy optimization it's a very generic
but useful machine learning algorithm
that kind of does lots of things kind of
well
it's not perfect for all situations
though
and here we have a specific set of
parameters for our car
that's really it
okay so i'm going to fire up this python
script and i'm going to show you how
this can work with more interesting
python i'm going to run this python
command ml agents learn which is just a
nice wrapper around ppo i'm going to
point it to our yaml file
and i'm going to give it an id okay
so that's going to fire up unity's ml
agents and then ask us to push play in
the unity editor
okay start training by pressing play
so if i push play in unity
this will start training tensorflow will
complain because that's what tensorflow
does
and then eventually it will start
training
with a bit of block
again this is very exciting there we go
okay so you can see here i'm gonna
shrink a little bit
this is training and slowly getting a
reward
what this is doing is taking completely
random actions in that minus one to one
action space
and
seeing how it's rewarded or penalized
okay if i go back to unity it will be
lagging but it will be kind of driving
so you'll see
it's moving the car around
when it gets penalized it gets penalized
when it gets rewarded gets rewarded and
we can see that reward happening here
if you're familiar with uh
tensorboard from
more serious machine learning projects
you can use that as well
so if i go here
and fire that up
you can see here this is all over the
place right now because it's really
early in its training run
but
it does show you what's going on so you
want the reward to go up slowly over
time
this is reinforcement learning so we're
pairing actions with observations and
rewards and trying to guide it towards
an optimal policy of driving now
realistically this will take you know
10 or so hours if we're leaving it to
train on my computer to get somewhere we
haven't got that much time so i'm going
to show you what i've prepared earlier
because that's what we do
so i'm going to kill that
you'll see here it wrote out an nn file
which is just a neural net from
tensorflow that's a
pv file
i already have one of those so i'm just
going to show you how it works very
exciting i'm going to go back into unity
and i'm going to go on to my brain which
is our learning brain here
and you'll see here we've got a slot for
a model
and i've got one i prepared earlier
which is this one
we want to infer on the gpu this is
actually not a problem not the kind of
situation we'd want to actually use a
gpu for but i'm going to leave it alone
and then i'm going to turn off that
control thing because we don't want
python to control it unity does not use
python for inference it only uses python
for training and i'll show you some more
python in a second for those of you who
prefer python to c-sharp things
i'm going to click play now this brain
was trained for about a day
and you'll see it's driving itself it's
as bad as i am basically at this point
but it is at least driving itself which
is a positive thing
that's very good that's very interesting
we can make a game that's really fun now
that's not the fun bit okay
python is the fun bit so
that's great we made it work but
if i turn this control thing back on and
remove the brain remove the model from
the brain
and
go into jupiter
so i have jupiter running here everyone
loves jupiter
i'm going to run some code here i'm
going to zoom in so you can see it i'm
going to say train mode true i'm going
to run that
i'm going to run some python code so
we're going to import matplot numpy
pill the usual stuff and we're going to
import some stuff from unity okay so i'm
going to run that one as well
i'm going to just check the python
version is correct
machine learning mostly often usually
kind of requires python 3.6
don't worry about it
we'll talk about it later if you have a
question um
i'm not going to ask unity to give me a
hand lights environment you'll see this
message we saw before start training by
pressing play unity so if i go back to
unity and hit play
then come back here you'll see it gets a
handle on the environment here and it
knows there's a learning brain with one
visual observation
no vector observation so there's no
numbers being fed into it only that one
visual observation
and it has an action space of one okay
so it can take that minus one or one
action
there's also the player brain which is
the thing i was using to steer it with
the keyboard you can see them both
now we can grab a handle on that and
just make sure we've got it so yep we've
got a handle on the learning brain here
i can now have a look at that
environment and print it out
so
there's no vector observations but i can
see out that camera so that's my 32 by
24 grayscale camera coming out of unity
i can keep running that so i can get
more of it was moving you know it's very
very interesting but now i can take
random actions in that environment so
here i am using python to basically say
take a random step using that continuous
action range so minus one to one in our
environment and do it ten times if i
click play
you'll see
i can spit this out in jupiter here
and this basically means you have
complete control of unity from within
python and you can make it do your
bidding you can ignore the machine
learning side if you want and just use
this to control unity and build a
simulation i know lots of people are
using unity to build environments that
are high enough fidelity representations
of the real world then they're using
unity cameras to capture images of that
and using it to train machine learning
for things that work in the real world
completely unrelated to the simulation
so if you need a really high fidelity
simulation and you want to capture it
with python this is a really good
solution for that this is kind of
mind-blowingly useful and when we finish
we close the environment which
disconnects it and releases unity back
to us
so this is a really useful thing if you
need to do something with machine
learning so i'm not going to go into any
more depth about the python stuff
there's a really good python api that
lets you
go through
everything this thing so there's a full
api here that you can use to
basically figure out
whatever you want to do and there's a
big python api here which lets you grab
stuff from the uni environment so you
can ignore the machine learning site and
just use this to control unity which is
something i recommend you start with
the thing i want to show you next in my
last 10 minutes or so is
how ridiculous this can get so
this is an environment that we didn't
build
but
i think is really cool so
if you've ever seen the uh
those ridiculous walking demos where the
things make themselves walk you can
implement that yourself
so this
this thing has taught itself to walk
kind of
this is about 12 hours of training
because i didn't have time because i my
computer booked itself yesterday or day
before so i had to retrain all these
this is about 12 hours of training this
thing i pull up the docs because i keep
forgetting this thing this thing has
this thing has 26 degrees of freedom on
a whole bunch of body parts hips chest
spine head thighs shins feet arms
forearms and hands its goal is to move
towards the goal direction and it gets
rewarded for velocity velocity in the
goal direction head position up so
staying upright
uh body direction alignment with goal so
it's not veering off its goal and it
gets penalized for head velocity
difference from body velocity
so
yeah that's basically how humans walk if
you unpack it that's not that's not
that's not meant to be funny that is how
humans walk and
it gets uh
observation space from the world it's
it's in so it can see the rotation
velocity angular velocity and the
position of all of those 215 different
variables of its joints
that basically means it ends up doing
this because
it's not it's not really walking so much
as it's kind of flinging itself in in
the direction of where it needs to be
however this has not been animated and
you can build anything you like using a
system like this so i'm just going to
unpack this a little bit more for you
because i think it's worth learning so i
still have 10 minutes left
i think i'll show you one more thing
we've built a little warehouse
okay so this is a little warehouse with
a little robot in it this robot needs to
push this cube into the goal over here
okay
so we've given this robot lasers he has
perfect lasers that can show
where he needs to be so his lasers are
these things if you see here he
has one two three four five six seven
lasers going out at different angles
around his body
he can detect the crate he can detect
the goal he needs to get to and he knows
what's a wall and he sends those that
set of lasers out twice one at one level
and one on another level okay
he gets rewarded uh sorry he gets
penalized for every single move he makes
which is designed to make him take
economy of movement so he's designed he
needs to take as minimal steps as
possible to achieve his goal uh and when
he delivers his package to the correct
place he gets five
okay
so
this is him this is him going
and you can see the lasers flashing i
can turn those off those are not part of
the environment but you see the little
guy pushing it around
he's pretty good at his job right
but we can make him really confused
really quickly which kind of
demonstrates
how and why machine learning does what
it does so we could code this pretty
quickly if we were just coding this as a
heuristic but this is learnt to push
this around
so if i
open a different version of the
warehouse where there's multiple goals
of different colors and multiple crates
but leave the machine learning brain
exactly the same
he's going to freak out so if you don't
feel comfortable seeing your robot freak
out
now is the time to look away
this robot knows that he needs to push
crates into goals but he doesn't have
any concept of color
so he just rapidly gets very stressed
he'll occasionally do something correct
he doesn't know he doesn't know why he's
getting he's basically getting hit every
time
something happens here uh if he gets
punished too much the environment resets
itself so you may see everything
disappear
uh
basically if he fails too much we kill
him um
i'm going to put him out of his misery
but before i put him out as i'm just
going to show you one quick really sad
thing
there's actually
hundreds of them
all going at once
it's because when you do machine
learning you want to train in parallel
so the more information you can feed
into the brain the better so often these
environments are duplicated repeatedly
so
this is just a really quick taste of
what you can do unity is completely free
if you're not using it to build video
games and making over a hundred thousand
dollars it's not open source the python
bridge lets you pretty much control
anything you like within unity and comes
with a bunch of scripts that allow you
to train things that do all sorts of
stuff without having to think about it
much
so if you are interested in learning
about machine learning this is a very
accessible way to getting into it it
uses tensorflow it uses all the industry
standard de facto standards for this
stuff so you're learning real useful
skills and you're doing it in a really
visual way okay you could even visualize
just a regular neural network but put it
in a visual form so you can see what's
going on so
we teach a lot of children how to do
machine learning with this and they
instantly grasp it when they can see it
moving
and it's really on open people's eyes
like nothing else i'm going to show you
one other thing i'm just going to give
you a bit of a content warning before i
show you it looks like a spider to some
extent so if you do not like spiders you
might want to look away it's not very
spider like it just has lots of legs
okay
so that is your warning
here is our spider it's gonna clear
those arrows okay so
this is a spider bop
that has taught itself to walk we built
this one it is uh its goal is to follow
that orange cube around the orange cube
is just moving around the environment
randomly the spider knows where it is
uh but doesn't know much else it can be
hit by it
it gets rewarded for facing it and
approaching it and getting close to it
it gets penalized for pretty much
everything else
and it told itself to walk so this is
pretty simple example pretty
straightforward but we thought you know
video game engine we need to make this
more something a gamer would like so we
gave the spiderbot a gun
uh so here is our spider bot and here's
our gun mount which i've turned off and
it's going to turn the gun mount on
so the gun is actually a completely
separate ai agent that is sitting on top
of the spider so it's effectively a
spider bot with a parasitic gun on top
they're both controlled by two
completely separate machine learning
brains that were trained with python
the bot is designed to seek the cube the
gun is designed to kill the cube
and they work together
so
you'll see he's got a gun now
it's pretty efficient so we did this we
did a version of this at pax the p
arcade expo which is a consumer gaming
show where we were trying to explain how
machine learning works to video gamers
with a capital video game and they
we are we hooked this up to a controller
so they could also play the robot and
attempt to destroy the cube quicker than
the bot and in the 30 seconds we let
them play the bot killed the cube 60
times and the human killed it twice
so
the machine overlords will win
eventually
but this is about
this is about an hour's worth of work in
in python and unity to get this going
excluding the visual aspects
the thing i really want to show you
before i finish is that this
behavior is
embedded in the object so if i go here
and i duplicate the robot
without doing anything else
and just move it slightly so there's a
couple of robots duplicate it again
duplicate it again
right so there's a couple of robots
there
and run this
there's now more than one robot in the
environment in theory
there are
so our camera is designed to track the
main robots i'll just uh
go into the scene here
they have no concept of each other
existing but they
know each other exists in the physics
engine so if you have enough of them
they'll eventually make a big pile of
robots where one will ascend to the top
they will they will use the others as a
platform with which to shoot the cube
and they'll just stay in this big
juttering juttering spiderbot pile
it's horrifying
it's legitimately horrifying
so i'm going to show you one more one
more thing quickly because i've still
got three minutes left so this is
another unity demo that we didn't make
uh it's this unity so i have lots of
unities open uh this is tennis
so this is tennis which is two hands
which are robots
trained with python that can play tennis
okay
and the fun thing about this one is you
can do imitation learning or behavioral
cloning so you can hook one hand up to a
human and have the other one learn how
to play the tennis based on the human
instead of based on reward signals so
you can do behavioral cloning
online by recording which is real time
using this algorithm and then you can
feed all the information into python and
tweak it to your heart's content so
that's unity with machine learning for
python i'm going to go back to my slides
and quickly finish i'm going to jump to
here
so
the brain is the thing that encapsulates
logic you can swap a brain out for being
controlled by a human or you can route
your blade to python to be controlled by
either a neural net you've trained or
for training purposes it's really
powerful
the agent is a thing inside unity which
is the thing you're controlling with
your brain it assigns rewards it's
linked to a brain it performs actions
okay so the agent in this case was the
robot the hands the spider bot the car
hopefully that makes sense
and these three objects exist inside
unity and then talk to python
to let you do the training okay
what we saw was reinforcement learning
today but you can also do imitation
learning as i said which is the
behavioral planning thing where you
teach it as a human what to do
really really powerful stuff can come
out of this
so the reinforcement learning we did
today was actions observations and
rewards we had some actions we wanted to
do which we rewarded
based on you know how it went and we've
got certain observations to to generate
those rewards or not
actions are just a number so you know
you can handle it however you like in
your game engine as you saw i was taking
-1 for one direction and one for the
other direction when we had the car that
can be whatever observations can be
vectors so you can you know distance to
a thing or a count or a number or be
pitchers coming from unity's cameras
rewards are just more numbers okay
reinforcement learning is just this
cycle of learning until you converge on
an optimal policy where it can actually
do the thing you want to do
brain academy agent
this is how it looks tensorflow is
communicating down the bottom
when you build an environment
you kind of want to think about how you
construct it this is pretty
straightforward stuff coming up with the
actions and observations is the really
tricky bit that's the out not the
science i recommend using the python
bridge to start with
uh via the unity ml agent's learn script
which is the pre-made things and then
moving to using jupyter and doing it
yourself
but you'll come up with a process here's
what you need you need unity you can get
it from here
it's really cool it's mostly free
build a simulation with a self-driving
car you play it like a game make it make
sure it works
you also need python i like anaconda but
you can use whatever environment you
like and you need a very specific
version of tensorflow because mustache
is machine learning something
and then you need ml agents which you
can get from pip that's pretty much it
i really really really like this
i think a game engine is a
really great way to learn machine
learning and i hope you try it out if
you're interested in doing this with a
completely open source game engine
there's a game engine called gotto
g-o-d-t-o
g-o-t-o-t
which is open source completely free and
has a similar project in the works which
works with tensorflow as well
thank you very much